now I know that they've said no but come
on what do we have to do to get the
Olsen twins on board for a little cameo
in season 2 I don't know we've tried
everything so no I think we've kind of
given up don't you have some cool celeb
cameos can you Tina we have a lot but I
can't well a lot of people that have
been talked about for like 30 years are
gonna be on the show give me a lot of
fun really yeah give me one can't tell I
can't Netflix will give me my last lot
leads how was the wedding planning going
I know you have your amazing man right I
do we're you know we're really excited
we're looking at the end of next year we
haven't started any planning for though
I've just been so busy this this year
with dance for the Stars and fuller
house but once this wraps and I have a
little bit of free time then we're gonna
start jumping into the planning what is
your one must-have at the wedding great
day and great food but both of them well
affray yep people our friends I mean our
friends most importantly everything else
will fall into place